every week for the past 16 years Maria
Katarina sumasi has come here to protest
she stands outside jakarta's
presidential Palace to demand Justice
her son was killed by security forces in
the late 1990s
over time I feel that my sorrow over
wawan's death has been transformed into
a determination to uphold law and human
rights the killing of more than a dozen
University students in Jakarta is one of
the dark chapters in Indonesian history
once again in the spotlight as president
Joko Widodo launches a Compensation
Program for victims of 12 past human
rights violations and their families
We Gather to heal the nation's wounds as
a result of past gross human rights
which have left a heavy burden on
victims and families
[Applause]
incidents also include Violence by
security forces in the province of
Archie in specific locations between the
1980s and the early 2000s Rouhani Jalil
says her entire family was tortured by
Security Forces including her two
children who were killed by personnel
the scheme will provide scholarships
Priority Health insurance money for home
renovations and opportunities for
vocational training
some victims have criticized the process
saying it doesn't hold perpetrators
accountable and doesn't help answer
questions about what happened to them or
their loved ones
the government says the program does not
interfere with legal Avenues but so far
no suspected perpetrator of Human Rights
abuses has ever been held accountable
some human rights groups have also
criticized the program as failing to
understand the needs of survivors
each failure of you know resolving human
rights violation through judicial and
non-judicial
will only
reinforces
the confidence of the perpetrators that
they are indeed above the law
back in Jakarta Maria says she will
continue to protest in honor of her son
she says the happiness of her family was
forcibly taken away and she doesn't want
the same fate for anyone else
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Ace
Indonesia